[Music]
welcome to Bible answers live where
you'll get honest answers to your Bible
questions let's face it it's not always
easy to understand everything you read
in the Bible with 66 books and more than
700 thousand words the Bible can
generate a lot of questions if you'd
like answers to your Bible questions
you've come to the right place now
here's your host pastor Doug Batchelor
president and speaker of amazing facts
hello friends would you like to hear an
amazing fact some described it as a hail
storm of biblical proportions on June 5
2018 severe storms swept through North
Texas around the DFW area pounding some
communities with baseball sized hail
residents reported it sounded like the
roofs were being beaten in with baseball
bats skylights were shattered car bodies
and windshields destroyed and trees were
decimated everywhere to confirm the
unbelievable size of the hailstones
several residents collected in
photograph samples some put them in
their freezer so others could look at
them later according to the Insurance
Council of Texas approximately 20,000
structures and 25,000 vehicles were
damaged for an estimated 425 million
dollars in losses one resident said I've
been here my whole life in North Texas
and the Dallas area and I've never seen
anything like this before you know the
Bible says just before Jesus returns
there'll be the mother of all hail
storms stay with his friends we're going
to learn more on this edition of Bible
answers live
[Music]
you're listening to Bible answers live
honest answers to your Bible questions
this broadcast is a previously recorded
episode to receive any of the Bible
resources mentioned in this evening's
program call 888-814-3923 so give us a
call it's an 800 460 372 97 that's 800
God says 804 63 7 297
we'll bring your questions into the
studio here in Northern California and
we're also streaming this live if you
want to tune in and watch it's on the
doug batchelor and the amazing facts
Facebook pages my name is Doug Batchelor
my name is John Ross good evening
listening frames and past the Duggars
you always do let's start the program
with prayer dear father in heaven we
thank you that we can open up your word
and study together this evening on a
number of questions and ideas and
various passages of Scripture so we do
pray that your spirit would lead our
thoughts and got our discussion lead us
in a clear understanding of what the
Bible teaches in Jesus name Amen amen
Oh pastor you opened the program but
talking about a terrible hailstorm
that's interesting when you look in the
Bible the Bible does speak about hail
being used by God on several occasions
to bring judgment upon the enemy of
God's people
mmhmm yeah actually the Lord fought
against some of the enemies of Israel
when they were entering the promised
land with hail of course before the
Exodus one of the 10 plagues he read
about this in Exodus 9 23 and Moses
stretched out his rod
heaven and the Lord sent thunder and
hail and fire darted to the ground
that's lightning and the Lord rained
hail on the land of Egypt so there was
hail and fire mingled with the hail so
very heavy
there was none like it in all the land
of Egypt since it became a nation and
the hail struck throughout the whole
land of Egypt and all that was in the
field both man and beast and tells us
prior verse they died and the hail
struck every herb of the field and broke
every tree of the field and I remember I
was in living in Texas a few years ago
we had hail it just it kind of scared us
you look out the window was walnut sized
hail not the baseball sized hail they
had a DFW but it I had a little Mazda
GLC and it was so sad because it came
out not just my car but every car that
was parked outside it looked like
someone had taken a ball-peen hammer and
does beat up the top of the car so the
rest of the time I had that car it
looked like the surface of the Moon and
I can't imagine that was just walnut
sized hail if if you've got baseball
sized hail you can see actual pictures
of it online these things are huge I
remember hearing a story by hms richards
senior who's the founder of the voice of
prophecy radio program when he was a
young man preaching on revelation one
day they were so tied up outside I had
some atheist was mocking him in the
congregation as he talked about the
planks and a hail storm struck in
Colorado right while he was preaching
and it's the stones were coming right
through the roof into the meeting hall
and he killed the horses outside and
it's a pretty dramatic story that fellow
was converted I was making fun of the
sermon on Revelation now what it says in
Revelation just one of the very last
plagues it comes revelation 1621 and a
great hail from heaven fell upon men
each hailstone the weight of a talent
that be somewhere around 75 pounds and
then blaspheme God because of the plague
of the hail since that plague was
exceedingly great well the Bible tells
us there is a day coming when it'll be
too late to pray and God is going to
punish the
world for their iniquity and we want to
know how to be ready before that day
comes and we have a free offer that
talks about that we've got a book and
we'll be happy to send this book out to
anyone who calls and asks it's cold the
last night on earth again this is free
oh you're left to do is call us on our
resource phone line the number is 883
five six seven four seven and as for the
book called the last night on earth
we'll be happy to send that to anyone in
North America if you're outside of North
America just go to the amazing facts
website amazing facts dot o-r-g or
dot-com and you can read the book for
free online it's called the last night
on earth and I think you find it very
enlightening as it talks about endtime
events and the second coming of Christ
all right well I think with that we're
probably ready to go to the phones we
still have a couple lines open if you
give us a call 800
says and who's first in line pastor Ross
we've got Ashley listening from Florida
Ashley welcome to the program hi good
evening bastards evening thank you for
calling and your question tonight thank
you
I was just wondering if you could
clarify Revelation chapter 14 verses 11
and 12 it kind of seems like it's
pointing towards an eternal hell and so
I just wanted some clarification on
those verses yeah if you read in
revelation 14:11 let me read it and the
smoke speaking of the wicked it says in
the smoke of their torment ascends
forever and ever and they have no rest
day or night who worshiped the beast in
his image and whoever receives the mark
of his name well first of all when it
says smoke goes up forever and ever that
simply says you've probably said well it
went on forever and that meant as far as
you could see and the smoke it's like
when Sodom and Gomorrah were destroyed
and the Bible tells us the wicked will
be destroyed like Sodom and Gomorrah
were destroyed and it tells us that the
smoke of the country went up like a
furnace and then it says in the presence
of the holy angels and the lamb you read
in the haunts Isaiah 60 is it 65 pastor
Ross where it says I'll go forth and
maybe it's 66 I'll go forth and look
on the carcasses of them that have
transgressed against me and their worm
will not die and they'll be according to
all flesh it's talking about beholding
the judgment of the wicked and you're
probably wondering about where it's a
day and night forever and ever
well first you've got to ask yourself
does that mean that the righteous are
gonna be forever and ever watching and
the lamb and the Holy Angels the wicked
burning the word forever there means
until they are all consumed now
someone's gonna say one second does
eternal life mean forever yeah
you got to read things in their context
the verse you're referring to their
pastor day was Isaiah 66 verse 24 you
know another way I heard this explained
with reference of the smoke a sinning
forever and ever
the smoke is the consequence of the fire
and some have seen it as emphasizing the
fact that the consequence of the fire
meaning death is eternal it there's no
resurrection from the second death so
just as the smoke symbolically ascends
up forever and ever so the consequences
of the judgment that comes upon the
wicked their eternal destruction and is
forever there is no end to that actually
one more thought now let's talk about
the day and night okay it says they have
no rest day or night who worship the
Beast now obviously the wicked are not
in in Hellfire still worshiping the
Beast so now it's talking about back
when they worshiped the Beast the people
who worship the Beast have no rest Jesus
had come unto me and I'll give you a
rest and so it's making a contrast
between those who worship Christ have
rest those who worship the Beast have no
rest they have no peace because
obviously in Hellfire they're not still
worshiping the Beast because he's been
cast in I'd be a pretty big mistake to
worship the one who's been cast into
hell fire see what I'm saying yeah so
people emphasize the day and night
forever and ever and they think that
means they're burning forever and ever
it's actually making a different point
in that part of the sentence hey thank
you Ashley and you know whenever you're
in doubt about a Bible verse you just
create a little scale and you can get a
piece of paper and say here's the you
know some people think that the fires of
hell are going to burn the wicked
through eternity lists those scriptures
get the other scriptures and make a list
the scriptures that say they're consumed
they perish they die they're destroyed
never will they be anymore no more pain
and we're crying and to start making a
column and you'll see wow the the
preponderance of evidence is on the side
that the wicked are ultimately consumed
in the fires of hell it's called the
second death
and then there's a few difficult verses
that you need to explain so that's
usually the best approach when there is
some apparent conflict thank you so much
we do have a study guide dealing with
the subject of Hell the destruction of
the wicked and it's called is the devil
in charge of Hell we'll be happy to send
this to anyone who calls and ask the
number is 883 five six seven four seven
this is an important subject and a lot
of Christians don't quite understand
what the Bible teaches on this and it's
important for us to know it again the
study guide is called is the devil in
charge of Hell and the resource line is
808 three five six seven four seven we
want to know God's plan for our world
and solutions for your life's challenges
beautifully redesigned amazing facts 27
Bible study guides provide encouraging
Bible based answers to questions on
healthier relationships when Jesus will
return and much more refer to watch
while you read our brand new prophecy
encounters DVD series makes the perfect
companion set order your study guides
and DVDs today by visiting AAF bookstore
comm or by calling 858 7275
we have Mia who is listening from
Maryland male welcome to the program
thank you for taking my call we do
pastor Doug and Pastor Ross evening my
question is it says that in New
Jerusalem when New Jerusalem comes down
there will be four gates why do we write
the New Jerusalem will have gates
usually we have gates to protect our
homes from intruders yeah that's a great
question sometimes we think of gates is
you're worried about some enemy army
invading but gates also are places in
the Bible gates and first of all there's
12 gates there's three on each side four
walls that says there's an gate is named
for each of the tribe
and the names of the apostles are in the
foundation stones but gates are also in
the Bible places where the judgment
happened gates were places where folks
would hear stories from the elders it
was like a gathering spot and we're
gonna be able to fly so you know the
walls are not like keeping people out of
the city Bible says they'll mount up
with wings like Eagle Eagles and so you
know you could fly over the gates if you
wanted to but I think it's a place where
just talks about you enter where those
verses says we enter his gates with
Thanksgiving so gates weren't always for
war just represented a boundary we
finally enter the City of God and of
course if you read in Revelation chapter
21 it talks about the New Jerusalem
coming down from God out of heaven in
chapter 20 it tells you when Jesus sets
his feet upon the Mount of Olives that
opens up forms a great valley the New
Jerusalem comes to rest and the wicked
are resurrected there outside the city
and the righteous are inside the city so
I'm sure at that point those gates will
be closed for the great white throne
judgment then the wicked mount their
attack upon the New Jerusalem and the
Bible says fire comes and devours them
so when the New Jerusalem is on the
earth they'll still be the wicked
outside the city and the righteous in
the city until the final judgment occurs
thank you thank you we do have a lesson
that talks about the New Jerusalem and
we'll be happy to send you a free copy
of that Maya it's called a colossal city
in space and we'll be happy to send this
to anyone who calls and asks the number
again he's eight hundred eight three
five six seven four seven you can ask
for the study guide on heaven it's
called a colossal city in space our next
caller that we have is Tyler and he's
listening from Oklahoma City Tyler
welcome to the program uh uh hi hi and
your question in Revelation 20 it talks
about how that the wicked will charge to
the New Jerusalem and then they will be
cast into the lake of fire but then
right after that it says that in the
great white throne of judgment they will
be cast into a lake of fire so I had a
confusion on window be cast into the
lake of fire well both those verses are
talking about the same
event it's referring back to the
original event again or the one time
when it says they're cast into the lake
of fire then it gives you more details
and it talks about it again you know we
also find a feature that B we see in
Bible prophecy is a you have a story or
a particular subject presented and then
sometimes as you read a little further
the Prophet is inspired to kind of back
up and give you some additional details
for example in Revelation chapter 20 it
talks about the wicked surrounding the
golden city the New Jerusalem but you
don't read until chapter 21 where the
New Jerusalem coming down out of heaven
so those two chapters overlap a little
bit with some of the details it's not
always in chronological order and that's
I think what confuses some people so
Tyler if I was just to tell you in in
layman's terms what's happening here in
revelation 22 it would be that the
wicked surround a revelation 20 also the
wicked surround the City of God they
launch an attack
they're called Gog and Magog all the
wicked who've ever lived and in the
midst of that attack Christ has exalted
above the city on his white throne
there's a mass judgment that takes place
and everyone whose names are not found
in the book of life is cast into a lake
of fire actually God rains fire and
brimstone down out of heaven upon them
forms a lake just like any rain can
eventually form a lake and there they've
got the consequences of being in that
lake of fire and every man is punished
according to what he deserves so we've
got a couple questions on Hell tonight
now that your question would fit with
our lesson on the Millennium Tyler we
have a special lesson on the Millennium
we'll send you a free copy if you call
and that lesson is called a thousand
years of peace and to receive that call
808 three five six seven four seven you
can ask to the study guide called
a thousand years of peace annex Qualys
kathleen listening from arizona kathleen
welcome to the program hi thank you hi
dr. pastor Doug and pastor John Ross
thank you for taking my call and thank
you for your ministry thank you
my question is pertaining to Psalms 55 I
was reading it and it seems like David
is asking God
to destroy the people who who have hurt
him
I am under the understanding that that
we should I don't know I pray for people
for God to soften their hearts that they
would turn to turn to God and repent and
be saved
should we pray for someone's destruction
if they're arming us well you know David
was a prophet and so you know we don't
have the insight he had sometimes when a
person is hurting others even Jesus was
so angry at the scribes and Pharisees
because they were blind leading others
to destruction the blind guides leading
the blind and some of the strongest
things that Jesus said he called him you
know a brood of vipers well I guess John
the Baptist said that he said woe to you
scribes and Pharisees hypocrites and so
Jesus had some pretty strong language
and he said they would there would be a
severe judgment he he said wept over
Jerusalem and and talked about the
severe judgment that was coming on them
because they had stoned the prophets and
done so many things so David David as
the king of the people he's he's he's
looking at the enemies of God's people
and what they've done to hurt God's
people and he wants them to stop hurting
the innocent so God has those same
emotions okay so like I don't know when
I see in the news where somebody I don't
know has killed a kid or something
I of course pray for their family for
comfort and but I also pray for that
person that they turn I don't wait no no
I think that's appropriate you know
that's one thing that makes Christians
unique is that we look beyond the sin
and we realize that if it wasn't for the
grace of God you know human hearts can
do desperately wicked and evil things
and we need to pray because there's
stories in the Bible of even there was a
king that even killed his own children
that later converted it's hard to
believe so you never can underestimate
God's power to transform someone maybe
because David was a prophet he knew
it that the one that was hurting him was
not going to change you yeah well and
keep in mind there there's two things
that you see here in the Bible one is
the law that has to do with
interpersonal relationships we should
turn the other cheek but then there's
civil law where it talks about an eye
for an eye
David here is probably speaking as a
king and he's dealing with civil law and
justice that must come upon the wicked
so you got several dynamics happening
here and thank you Kathleen we
appreciate your question a next caller
that we have is Inez listening from
Billings Montana - welcome to the
program thank you thank you and your
your question ah my son and I are
distance study and we are looking to see
where in the Bible it says that we have
a garden each one of us has a guardian
angel well there's a couple of verses
you don't find the word guardian angel
in the Bible or the phrase but you do
have a few verses you can look at Psalm
91 verse 11 he will give his angels
charge over you to keep you in all of
your ways and then there's the verse sin
maybe pastor oz was looking that one up
in Matthew Matthew 18 10 says take heed
that you do not despise one of these
little ones for us and to you that in
heaven their angels always see the face
of my father who is in heaven
so guardian angels dickly here it's
referring to little children and says
they're angels
so that we give you the idea of an a
guardian angel and the Lord has no
shortage of angels the Bible describes
them as you know ten thousand times ten
thousand and thousands of thousands so
you know God could appoint angels to
watch over humans we know the devil has
evil angels that are trying to trip us
up and tempt us and not too many people
argue that they are free of temptation
so if Devils got enough angels to go
around and tempt us to sin then we know
that God has got two good ones for every
bad ones that's in Revelation is it 12
where it says the third of the angels
are cast out two-thirds were good and
they're there to help us resist the
devil
was that person revelation revelation 12
it talks about Satan this cast out of
heaven and his angels were cast out with
him and it says that he drew a third of
the stars to the earth and later tells
us these are the angels so Satan was
able to persuade one-third of the angels
to follow him in his rebellion against
the creator thank you so much all right
hey thank you and good question we've
got Debra listening in Burbank
California Debra welcome to the program
hi Debra I was born in Burbank I know
that's what I told my called in well
that's why we gave you we gave you
special access my question is why is
there confusion over the number in the
Godhead you mean being whether there's
three be three individual persons or one
yes well you know first of all in in all
honesty I think people in in our culture
struggle with the idea of one we always
think when the Bible says hear o Israel
the Lord our God is one we think about
numerical quantity that this is one but
you read the rest of the Bible and the
word one did not always mean numerical
quantity it often meant unity it's like
Jesus said I and my father are one
well we know there are different persons
because there at the baptism you've got
Jesus in the water and God the Father
says this is my son and Jesus was not
doing a ventriloquist job at that time
and Christ said to the Apostles father I
pray they may be one as you and I are
one and Jesus said a husband and wife
get married and they become one flesh so
the word one for the Hebrew often meant
unity a purpose and direction that you
kind of one body you know when the Bible
tells us that God is Father Son and Holy
Spirit in Genesis God says let us make
man in our image so the plural is used
there there had to be at least two and
we read in the New Testament there were
three okay so now I've got a book I just
finished on this I always believe that
there's three yeah well you're right the
I've got a book that I just wrote as a
lot of people have questions on this and
it's on the Trinity it says it's called
the Trinity one God or three and if you
call amazing facts we will send you a
copy of that book
have a fabulous I appreciate that sure
we got I got a whole list in the back of
the book of like 24 quotes from
Scripture that mentioned the three
persons of the Godhead in one or two
verses together the number the call for
that is eight hundred eight three five
six seven four seven and again just
after the book on the Trinity I'll be
happy to send it to you eight hundred
eight three five six seven four seven
we've got Jerry listening from Oregon
Jerry welcome to the program good
evening pastors Ross and Bachelor always
a nice talking to you
I saw your sermon online two days
there's Saturday morning and you
mentioned that many many people in
mainstream Christianity believed that
Sabbath was chases Sunday because Jesus
was appeared on Sunday which is true
I've heard that too but my question to
you yes the Bible makes it clear he was
seen Sunday morning but that doesn't
mean he was necessarily resurrected on
Sunday morning he could have been
resurrected twelve hours earlier do you
what do you know any scriptures a tip
that pinned down his actual time of
resurrection well I think there are
scriptures
you know I'm looking right now in Luke
chapter 24 verse 1 and it says now on
the first day of the week very early in
the morning they insert another women
came to the tomb bringing spices they
went they didn't find the body of Jesus
we believe that you know he had risen
shortly before that and I'm friend
remember which one of the Gospels it
says the angel of the Lord descended and
the soldiers did quake and he threw
aside the stone is that Matthew 28 let
me see yeah here it is in Matthew 28
verse 2 behold there was a great
earthquake and it says on the first day
of the week a great earthquake the angel
of the Lord descended from heaven came
and rolled back the stone from the door
and sat on it and his countenance was
like lightning so the
Angell rolling back the door from which
Christ ultimately emerges that
definitely happened Sunday morning
well yes but he could have rolled away
the stone just so that these ladies
could go into the tomb
it still doesn't specifically say that
Jesus was resurrected at that time you
know I think that the contextually it's
clear but I suppose you could argue that
well after you read the passage you just
looked at I think you Matthew pass that
I get talks about the angel coming down
from heaven the soldiers fell to the
ground as though they were dead I need
you rolled away the stone doesn't
specifically state that Jesus rose from
the dead but when the soldiers kind of
came around they got up and ran back to
Jerusalem and they gave the message that
Christ was resurrected from the dead so
it was evident to them that Christ rose
from the dead at the same time that the
angel had rolled away the stone well of
course the angel in mark 16 he says that
he's not here he is risen
I think the angel is making it sound
like this imminently had just happened
that's in mark chapter 16 and the first
few verses hey we don't mean to cut you
off Jerry but we've got to take a hard
break right now we'll be back more
questions don't go away
[Music]
stay tuned Bible answers live we'll
return in a moment
[Music]
deep within the pages of the Bible
stories of great heroes heroes of great
deeds great love and great sacrifice but
behind them is another hero hidden in
plain sight amid the shadows he was
there from the beginning
and he'll be there until the end
discover the golden thread of a savior
woven throughout the entire bible
tapestry
shadows of light seeing Jesus in all the
Bible get your copy today by calling
[Music]
855-578-6767 study guides plus a Bible
numbers and symbols charts and eight
pages of colorful maps this best-ever
Bible gives you a biblical cyclope dick
index words of Christ in red chronology
of the Old Testament
along with Doug bachelors how to study
the Bible feature and much more call us
at AF bookstore to learn more about it
at one eight hundred five three eight
seventy two seventy five duty no amazing
backs has a free Bible school that you
can do from the comfort of your own home
it includes twenty seven beautifully
illustrated study lessons to aid in your
study of God's Word
sign up today for this free Bible study
course by calling 1-800 for two hundred
fifty seven thousand that's one eight
four four two one five seven thousand
[Music]
every bible question you have answered
moves you one step closer to the
fullness of God's will for your life so
what are you waiting for get the answers
you need for a fuller richer more
confident life you're listening to Bible
answers live this broadcast is a
previously recorded episode if you'd
like answers to your Bible related
questions on the air please call us next
Sunday between 7 p.m. and 8 p.m. Pacific
time to receive any of the Bible
resources mentioned in this evening's
program call 888-814-3923
my name is John Ross and we gonna go to
our next caller we have Scott listening
in Nebraska Scott welcome to the program
hello good evening pastors how are y'all
tonight good how can we help you my
question is at the end when we see Jesus
coming in the clouds where exactly is
Satan gonna be is he still gonna be
trying to deceive people or I know he's
gonna be on the earth but where exactly
didn't fix it does it say he is gonna be
when when all this happens well some
would argue that he's going to make some
kind of a grand appearance in the Holy
Land they read where it tells us in this
at 2nd Thessalonians it's in the temple
of God showing himself he is God mm-hmm
I think Satan's gonna maybe appear in
number places around the planet
impersonate Jesus where he'll be
geographically exactly when Christ comes
I don't know
he might be in Washington DC but he's
gonna be going around the planet
you know impersonating Christ and trying
to win people over to worship Him so we
won't be able to see Satan as a glory of
light and Jesus coming in the clouds
well the glory of Christ when he comes
is going to eclipse any earthly glory
any being on earth there'll be nothing
like it
Satan yeah you know he's he's a created
being some of argued you know is Satan
going to appear as a man or is he
somehow going to be you know taking on
the form of a man I don't think Satan
has the power of incarnation like Jesus
did that that's a mystery that only God
could perform but Satan is somehow going
to appear in the form of a man to
deceive humans Wow okay yeah all right
he may possess he may just thoroughly
possess an individual you know he's done
that in history before okay well I
appreciate your answers well very good
thank you Scott and yes some of these
things we're just gonna have to we're
gonna have to wait and see Chris we're
not looking forward to that part of the
story we do have we get a lesson we can
send you on the Antichrist and it's
simply cold who is the Antichrist and
we'll be happy to send this to you Scott
or anyone would like to receive it the
number is 883 five six seven four seven
and again you can ask the study guide
called who is the Antichrist again 800
eight three five six seven four seven
next caller that we have is Mac
listening from Washington Mac welcome to
the program
not even in pastors how are you great
thank you for calling well I have the
question that I have has to do with
asking the Lord for signs you know if
there's you know you have a decision you
need to make in your life and you want
the Lord's input on it and you know I've
read in different places that we
shouldn't tempt the Lord that way or try
him that way but then they're stories
about Gideon and and the police on the
ground so I just wanted some
clarification about that yeah well
you're right there you know Christ does
say in Matthew chapter it was a 12 verse
39 an evil and adulterous generation
seeks after a sign and know
sign will be given except the sign of
the prophet Jonah so Christ is not
condemning there are ever asking for
some divine guidance you know of course
he wants us to follow his word sometimes
if you want leading to look in the word
and sometimes you'll speak through
Christian counsel other believers that
have wisdom he'll guide us with the
impressions of his Spirit but I've been
in situations before I think and a lot
of Christians have were you just you had
two good alternatives you just say Lord
I meet some additional evidence to make
my decision and I've seen where God has
given signs the disciples when they
needed to pick a new apostle to replace
Judas they cast lots that's essentially
asking for a sign you know sometimes the
Lord would he'd give some providential
evidence that would guide people but I
think most of all Christ had best
Blissett are those who believe without
seeing so when he was talking to the
scribes and Pharisees and he said it's
an evil a generation that seeks after a
sign Christ was saying look you got the
sign of the prophets to know that I'm
the Messiah you don't believe the
prophets he won't believe me
you shouldn't be asking for a sign that
I'm the Messiah I don't think that was a
blanket statement we should never ask
for any kind of extra evidence I know a
lady that was really praying with Anat
she should marry a man and a very godly
woman it's just not knowing and just
wanting to know she did indeed knelt by
her bed and opened the Bible and closed
her eyes flipped through the Bible just
put her finger down on a page and she
put her finger down on the part in
Genesis 22 I think where were they
looking for a wife for Isaac and it says
you know if he bids you go with him she
married the guy who is happily married
but she says she just needed a sign so
sometimes God does that but it's best
not to depend on flipping coins and
looking for signs well I guess what I
wanted to know is there's lots of times
that you know I'm a Christian and you
know I'm looking to do the Lord's work
at every chance I get and then it's just
sometimes you know I just want to know
is this what you want you know what is
what is your purpose for my life
what a thing you know uh huh and and
there are things that I would do I think
of doing and I would say the Lord is
this it you know if this is it she
me to sign and show me that sign you
know so I mean how does that how does
that work the best thing is say Lord
guide me and then start reading the
Bible and you'll find that the Lord will
bring you to passages it's like he's
saying I speak to you primarily for my
word he will lead you to passages now
I've got a book I can send you where I
talked specifically about this Henry and
it's called how to know the will of God
and it talks about looking for leading
in these situations again the number the
call for that is 808 three five six
seven four seven and after the book
called determining the will of God and
will be happy to send it out to you Mac
or anyone who calls and asks my next
call of the behaved is Henry listening
from New York Henry welcome to the
program yes from the room from New York
and the New Year suppose thank you
with Rose before Cleopatra or after
Moses was before Cleopatra yeah
Cleopatra lived closer to the time of
Julius Caesar and that would have been
about 50 BC and Moses lived about 900
years before that so yeah he definitely
lived quite a ways before then so when
he was in Egypt long before Cleopatra
came around alright thank you for your
call Henry our next caller that we have
is Latham listening from Alberta Canada
Latham welcome to the program thank you
um my question is if God knows the
future so well why did he create Lucifer
well God creates creatures free and the
Lord was willing to make Lucifer
even though God knew that he might rebel
it's like when your parents decided to
have children
they probably knew in advance that the
children may not always obey them but
they wanted to love their children and
so they took the risk well God he
doesn't make us robots he makes us free
and so God even made a an angel that had
the potential to go bad Lucifer's going
bad was his decision it wasn't God's
choice God is a loving God and that's
why he does it you know we have Latham
we have a study guide called the
God make a devil and it talks about you
know why would God create an angel that
he knew could go bad and to receive that
study guide all you're left to do is
call our resource phone line that's 808
three five six seven four seven and
again after that study guide called did
God create a devil will be happy to send
that to anyone who calls and asks
journey back through time to the center
of the universe discover how a perfect
angel transformed into Satan the
arch-villain the birth of evil a
rebellion in heaven that moved to earth
behold the creation of a beautiful new
planet and the first humans witness the
temptation of evil
discover God's amazing plan to save his
children this is a story that involves
every life on Earth every life the
cosmic conflict if God is good if God is
all-powerful if God is love then what
went wrong
Mexico Lee is poaching a guest listening
from Florida porch Lee welcome to the
program yes how you doing my question
isn't our version of deal we which which
are alive and remain shall be caught up
together with them in the clouds to meet
the Lord in the air 1st Thessalonians 4
yeah yes yes now would that be
is that 144,000 that's caught up in that
well they may be some of them but we
don't think it's only 144,000 that are
saved because when you read in
Revelation chapter 7 and 14 where talks
about 144,000 principally chapter 7 it
says there's also a great multitude that
no man can number the 144,000 will
certainly be part of that group but
they're not the only ones there's gonna
be another group they also wouldn't
Christ we - yeah well you the hundred
and forty-four thousand just it says
there twelve thousand from the twelve
tribes that's that's sort of a spiritual
term talking about those who have come
to believe in Jesus there may be some
literal Jews and spiritual Jews in that
group but they're like leaders like the
Twelve Apostles were leaders they were
not the only ones that Jesus saved at
Pentecost there were 120 in the Upper
Room and then through their preaching
there was 3,000 saved and that all began
with the Twelve Apostles Jesus trained
so the twelve the hundred and forty-four
thousand if only 144,000 are saved and
now there's you know pushing eight
billion people in the world I did the
math once and that would mean your
chances of being saved are 1 out of
50,000 so that's pretty sad you know I
wouldn't want to be hoping that I'm 1
out of 50,000 there's gonna be a lot
more than that saved in the last days
you know we do have a book talking about
144,000 we'll be happy to send that to
you it's called who will sing the song
understanding 144,000 the number to call
is 883 five six seven four seven and
again the book is called who will sing
the song understanding the 144,000 that
we read about in Revelation amen
thanks for your call our next call is
Alan listening from Mississippi Alan
welcome to the program thank you so much
truly a pleasure
you blessed way four years so thank you
appreciate your calling well thank you
sir in numbers thirteen one the children
of Israel in the wilderness number
thirteen one says the Lord said to Moses
send some men to explore the land of
Canaan yes it's been in Deuteronomy 122
it appears that the Israelites came to
Moses said let's send some spies and
Moses said it seemed like a good idea to
me yeah you're wondering it sounds like
a contradiction yes sir well the way
I've had it explained in looking at the
different commentaries is it was
initially the people's idea they went to
Moses said you know Moses you've
actually never been in the Promised Land
Moses you know he wandered 40 years in
the wilderness he never crossed the
Jordan and the other Israelites had not
been there you know for several
generations they said we probably ought
to send some surveillance out there to
see what's going on you know we don't
know God's promises land but all we have
is hearsay and so it was the people's
lack of faith initially they said let's
send some spies now it wasn't
necessarily a bad idea to have spies
because later Joshua 40 years later
Joshua sent spies and Joshua was one of
the original twelve spies so God then
consents and what you're reading in
numbers 13 is God consenting to the
request of the people so the Lord said
to Moses send men to spy out the land
but he's not responding to a request
that's already been made by the people
so the the idea started with the people
and Moses said well it sounds good Lord
they want to send spies and God said
okay but it wasn't initially God's idea
does that make sense yes sir absolutely
thank you so much Thank You Alan
appreciate that next one that we have is
Damien listening from Miami Florida
Damien welcome to the program thank you
goodnight and Posterous evening and how
can we help you tonight okay I was
reading Genesis chapter 1 verse 27 what
does it mean to be created God created
man in his own image yeah that's great
well God actually has a form so for one
thing man is made in a similar form of
God God does not look like a giraffe or
his
or a mouse or flying squirrel if we want
to know something about what God looks
like we look like him just like a child
may have a striking resemblance to its
parents God has a head in hands and feet
like us he walks up erect there are a
couple of images where you see God in
the Bible in Daniel chapter 4 Daniel 7
revelation 1 zekiel I don't remember
what chapter but these different
prophets saw the Lord Isaiah 6 sitting
God sitting on a throne he's got you
know eyes and hair and and it clothes
like a human so we're made in that form
in the image of God but man is made in
the image of God in that God creates and
man was made to procreate in our image
so when we have children like God we
have children in our own image
God is a ruler man was made to be the
ruler of this planet
God gave dominion of the world to Adam
and Eve so that's another way that man
is made like God and there are many
other characteristics and emotions we
have that we get from God does that make
sense
thank you very much okay hey thank you
Damien appreciate that
good question next police Roger
listening from Colorado Roger welcome to
the program thank you for having me my
question concerns something that was
asked earlier okay when Jesus was
resurrected from the grave
I understand somebody had said something
about that there were other
resurrections at about the same time is
that true well they're talking in
Matthew 20 27 that's 427 52 it tells us
that at the time the Christ died there
was an earthquake many of the graves
around Jerusalem were shaken open and
after the resurrection of Christ
some of them came out of their graves
and appeared to people in the city they
we understand ascended to heaven when
Christ did so there was a small group of
people that were resurrected at the same
time as Christ according to Matthew
chapter 27 well I thank you very much
for that and thank you also for Friday
night Bible question oh thank you we
appreciate your calling take care roger
you got it thank you
next for the behalf is Joe listening
from Pennsylvania Joe welcome to the
thank you good evening pastures you name
thank you for calling yes I would I
would like your comments on Matthew 15
10 through 20 and mark 7 14 through 21 I
know you probably answered this some
hundred times but unfortunately I've
never heard your answer these scriptures
talk about the what goes into the body
that's not to follow the body it is what
comes out of the body and to me it seems
to be talking about food because it says
what goes in is eliminated correct yeah
what part what the issue here though is
not a particular kind of food what the
dispute is over is the religious leaders
were giving the apostles a hard time
because they did not ceremonially wash
their hands before they ate and jesus
said you know don't you realize that
that's not what defiles you if you eat
with dirty hands it doesn't defile your
heart he wasn't making that statement as
a blanket that a person can eat anything
that might crawl across their plate that
now people you know that the unclean
food suddenly were cleansed some people
read it that way but Jesus is talking to
Jews they they had no discussion there
was no dispute here about what clean
foods were an unclean foods the dispute
here is if you wash if you eat with
unwashed hands ceremonially unwashed
hands does that defile your heart Jesus
said no you know we eat a certain amount
of bacteria every day and it goes
through your digestive system that's why
Christ said purging all meats there's a
certain purging that takes place and it
like you say it's eliminated it kind of
goes in and comes out and it doesn't
defile your heart but you know God bless
Daniel when Daniel said he would not
defile himself with the unclean foods
that the king of Babylon was wanting to
feed them also the religious leaders in
the time of Jesus laid a heavy burden
upon the people the common people in
order for them to eat they would have to
go through this ceremonial washing
otherwise they would be defiled and this
was difficult for a lot of the common
people especially the poorer people and
Jesus in this whole passage was talking
to the religious leaders and said you
are making void the law of God by your
man-made
traditions and then he uses this one for
example the washing of cups and
ceremonial washing of the hands and then
he called the multitude together this is
the people and he said understand it's
not you know what goes into the mouths
meaning it's not the ceremonial washing
of the hands and the cups that's really
the most important thing it's what comes
out of the heart so Jesus was
illustrating that truth the context
there is these traditions created by the
religious leaders and then later in
Matthew chapter 12 he said out of the
abundance of the heart the mouth speaks
and we're defiled by our words actually
we'll be judged by our words if you're
wondering about whether God still cares
if we eat clean or unclean food what
Jesus teaching was on that you jump to
Acts chapter 10 which happens about four
years after the death of Christ Peter
has a vision and he says not so Lord I
have never eaten anything common or
unclean so if the disciples who lived
surrounded by Greeks and Romans we're
thinking it was okay to eat anything
well they sure weren't doing it even
four years after Christ because Peters
speech says very explicitly I've never
eaten anything common and he never takes
anything out of this visionary sheet and
eats it so that was a vision about
preaching the gospel to the Gentiles
right yes okay well thank you yeah so
yeah you know buzzards and skunks and
camels are still unclean I want to eat
them yeah I just heard a pastor say one
time he said you know if if you say that
every creature of God is good and you
think that you can eat any living thing
well technically that would be an
endorsement of cannibalism so God is not
saying that mm-hmm
did you know amazing facts has a free
Bible school that you can do from the
comfort of your own home it includes 27
beautifully illustrated study lessons to
aid in your study of God's Word sign up
today for this free Bible study course
by calling 184 257,000 that's one eight
four four two one five 7,000
next wall of the behaved is Lindsay
listening from Michigan
Lindsay welcome to the program hi Pastor
dog and pastor oz all right thank you
for calling yes so my question is is did
people back in Bible times know that
they were fulfilling prophecy and a
couple of examples that I was wondering
about was when Mary and Joseph went to
Bethlehem for the birth of Jesus
when Herod commanded the slaughter of
children and when Jesus rode the donkey
I know that was all prophesized I think
in the book of Isaiah I'm not for sure
but I was just curious about that yeah
well when Christ rode the donkey I think
that's a karate yeah yeah Jesus knew he
went Joseph now I know you were talking
about Joseph Jesus father when Joseph
the patriarch was in Egypt near the end
of his life he told his brothers I know
that the prophecy God gave me as a young
man that he had all bowed down to me and
that he would bring good out of it now I
know what that prophecy is all about so
Joseph lived to see a prophecy God gave
him fulfilled that's Joseph the son of
Jacob
I don't think Mary and Joseph realized
when they tied off their donkey in
Bethlehem before Jesus was born
hey let's hurry up and go fulfill this
prophecy I think it was the last thing
in their mind Mary had been told by
Gabriel that you're gonna have the
Messiah but I'm not sure that they they
were going to Bethlehem because there
was a tax and they had to go I don't
think they thought let's hurry and get
this so that we could look like we're
fulfilling Micah's prophecy what do you
think yeah no one's ever asked me that
before those scrolls were not available
well no they had the scrolls but you
know there's a lot of there's a lot of
prophecies in the Bible I'm not sure
that they had made the connection
because Micah's prophecy Bethell him out
of you will come forth he who will be
Savior I'm not sure that they had always
put two and two together on that we
pretty certain that Herod did not
realize that he was actually fulfilling
Bible prophecy when he had all the
little baby boys put to death of course
there was a formula prophecy did you
read later on but in the story of the
wise men that came from the east and
they saw the star they had been studying
the scriptures and I understood that
that had prophetic importance and so
they followed the star so
yeah they are some who recognize the
phone of prophecy and some who didn't
okay well thank you guys so much for all
your work yes I really appreciate it
all right god bless have a good one next
one that we have is Jim listening in
Oregon
hey Jim we've got about a minute and a
half can we do it oh sure sure
we'll try the top a new millennium where
the the people of God in heaven and the
person comes down and Jesus resurrects
the wicked dead oh the Satan is loosed
some change because the wicked dead
heard now alive but ministers that he's
in is loosed and the season I see that
one a days a year seizure in his three
months rent that he's going to be
tempting the wicked for nine
years all right so what Jim is let me
just repeat your question because you're
cutting in and out we're gonna put you
on hold mute here because they were
getting some feedback I think Jim is
asking when it says in revelation 20
that Satan is loosed from his prison for
a little season and he'll go out and
deceive the nation's how long is that
little season I think it's a phrase that
is used is indefinite
the closest I've heard is you know Moses
he refused to be called a son of Pharaoh
wrath willing to suffer affliction with
the people of God than to enjoy the
pleasures of sin for a season and some
have said well that was 40 years or 80
years and so I've heard arguments about
you know maybe Moses life a season there
it just means a spell of time there are
season for us can be the what he call it
the cycle of the seasons which is one
year if you look at the translation of
this New King James verse 3 it says
shall be released for a little while so
that I'd use the word cease and they'd
just say a little while yeah that kind
of cell that sums it up hey I hope that
helps a little bit Jim we appreciate
your question I don't know that we'd
have time to do justice to our last
caller Angelita give us a call next week
if you don't mind giving us a call we'll
try and put you at the head of the list
here listening friends before you go
away let me just remind you that
amazing facts has a broad spectrum of
ministry this Bible answer program is a
service we do once a week because you
just love to study the word with people
and get the truth out there we've got a
Bible School we have missionary training
we have television programs around the
country
we're on stations like TBN and Daystar
and lifetime and many others hope you'll
go to our website and check out amazing
facts it's simply amazing facts dot
o-r-g and keep in mind everything we do
is only by the grace of God working
through you
we have no corporations or denominations
that underwrite us it's just folks like
you that say hey I've been blessed I
want to help you keep going you can go
to amazing facts and click donate and
you'll know what to do thank you so much
for studying the Word of God with us and
God willing we'll be back together again
to do it again next week thank you for
listening to today's broadcast
we hope you understand your Bible even
better than before Bible answers live is
produced by amazing facts a faith-based
ministry located in Sacramento
California
[Music]
hello friends pastor Doug Batchelor here
with amazing facts Corrine was divorced
pregnant and very concerned about her
future but God saw her in her desperate
loneliness and confusion and he used a
co-worker to share an amazing fact DVD
that led Corrine to our website here at
the website she studied our life
changing free online Bible studies what
she learned there transformed her heart
and today Corrine has a lasting peace
she's baptized and part of a nurturing
church family now you friend
have an opportunity to help someone
today and to make an eternal difference
for more people like Corrine you're a
simple investment of faith and amazing
facts
we'll keep growing and reaching more
people with God's life-changing word
would you prayerfully consider sending a
gift today to help others know Christ
and the wonderful truth that changes
hearts and it's easy to make a donation
give us a call at 877 five zero six one
seven five one the number again eight
seven seven five zero six one seven five
one or just visit give dot amazing facts
dot o-r-g or send your gift to peel box
10:58 Roseville California nine five six
seven eight
thank you for studying the Word of God
with me today and I hope that you plan
now to join me again next week as we
discover more amazing facts from the
god did you know that Noah was present
to the birth of Abraham okay maybe he
wasn't in the room but he was alive and
probably telling stories about his
floating zoo from the creation of the
world to the last day events of
Revelation Bible history calm is a free
resource where you can explore major
Bible events and characters enhance your
knowledge of the Bible and draw closer
to God's Word go deeper visit Bible
History com4 life-changing Christian
resources visit AF bookstore calm or
call one eight hundred five three eight
seven two seven five if you'd like to
enhance your study of God
you